die koalition und ihre letzten projekte
vor der sommerpause die pflegereform
steht aber beim klimagesetz hakt es gibt
wieder streit um die mehrkosten fürs
heizen so viele corona tote wie sonst
nirgends auf der welt peru hat jeden
zweihundertsten einwohner durch die
pandemie verloren und ein sieg musste
her und es war sehr knapp aber jetzt
steht das deutsche eishockey team bei
der wm im viertelfinale
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend hinein
willkommen bei uns an diesem nachrichten
mittwoch christian ist auch hier und hat
nachher den sport nur gutes guten abend
es sind milliardenschwere pläne die die
bundesregierung jetzt auf den weg bringt
eine pflegereform für deutschland
profitieren davon sollen nicht nur die
dringend gesuchten pflegekräfte die
pläne allerdings stoßen bereits auf
protest
und so soll die pflegereform aussehen ab
september kommenden jahres können heime
und pflegedienste dann nur noch mit den
kassen abrechnen wenn sie nach tarif
bezahlen
finanziert wird das ganze zum einen
durch einen höheren beitrag für menschen
ohne kinder
er steigt um 0,1 prozentpunkt außerdem
schießt der bund jährlich eine milliarde
euro zu die pflegebedürftigen sollen
entlastet wird heike slansky eigentlich
ein guter tag für die altenpflege heute
und die beschäftigten denn auf den
letzten metern hat sich die
bundesregierung auf höhere löhne
verständigt doch das allein reicht fiel
nicht das macht erstmal zufrieden
aber am ende des tages hilft und dann
auch nicht wir brauchen die anpassung
dass mehr hände zur verfügung stehen
während der arbeitszeit die spd-spitzen
dagegen zufrieden besucher im lazarus
pflegeheim in berlin um die frohe
botschaft zu verkünden ein kompromiss
nachdem mehrere anläufe der großen
koalition pflegekräfte besser zu
entlohnen gescheitert waren
wir haben jetzt sichergestellt dass
zukünftig einrichtungen die geld aus der
pflegeversicherung bekommen nur dann das
geld bekommen wenn sie die beschäftigten
nach tarif bezahlen und das ist auch
richtig so in deutschland denn
mindestlohn reicht nicht klatschen
reicht nicht etwa die hälfte der rund
1,2 millionen beschäftigten würden laut
bundesgesundheitsministerium profitieren
bis zu 300 euro mehr im monat trotzdem
soll es für heimbewohner nicht teurer
werden deshalb ein zuschuss für
pflegebedürftige prozentual gestaffelt
von jahr zu jahr ab dem dritten jahr
wären das rund 600 euro im monat
finanziert mit bundeszuschüssen und
einem erhöhten beitrag für kinderlose
ich weiß dass das ein sehr emotionales
thema ist
aber hier geht es ja um die
wirtschaftliche die finanzielle
belastung die ist und bleibt
unterschiedlich bei familien im
vergleich zu denjenigen die eben nicht
auch geld in die kinder investieren
gott sei dank haben die sich kurz vor
ultimo noch geeinigt kritisch ist
natürlich zu betrachten was inhalt ist
der bundeszuschuss ist grundsätzlich gut
aber in der höhe zu gering eine reform
die noch der zustimmung des parlaments
bedarf und wohl auch wegen der offenen
finanzierung die nächste regierung
beschäftigen wird überhaupt nicht mehr
am selben strang zieht die koalition in
berlin beim streit um heizkosten da
könnten für mieterinnen und mieter
deshalb jetzt erheblich mehr kosten
zukommen eigentlich sollte der neue co2
preis der das heizen verteuern wird zu
gleichen teilen von mietern und
vermietern gezahlt werden das war der
kompromiss den die cdu csu fraktion
jetzt aber nicht mehr mittragen will
florian hahn hat die rein zu halten
mindestens ungewöhnlich ist heute gleich
mehreres etwa wie scharf der spd
vizekanzler die union attackiert wir
wissen dass jetzt die preise zum
beispiel für das heizen in den wohnungen
teurer werden auch wegen der in diesem
jahr begonnenen co2 bepreisung deshalb
will ich schon sagen dass ich sehr
empört darüber bin dass eine lobby einen
koalitionspartner fest im griff hat es
geht um die co2 abgabe die seit anfang
des jahres auf das heizen fällig wird
bisher zahlen allein mieter die
mehrkosten
vor drei wochen hatte die
bundesregierung verabredet künftig
sollen sich mieter und vermieter die
abgabe teilen zustimmung dazu auch von
unions ministern mindestens ungewöhnlich
ist aber auch was dann geschieht die
unionsfraktion fällt den eigenen
ministern in den rücken und der für
heute geplante kabinettsbeschluss ins
wasser worauf nicht nur der
koalitionspartner mit scharfer kritik
reagiert
die mieterinnen und mieter bezahlen ihre
normalen heizkosten aber sie haben
keinen einfluss darauf welche heizung
eingebaut ist und deshalb ist eine
kostenteilung richtig und so hört die
unionsfraktion einen vorwurf heute öfter
dass sie einknicken vor der immobilien
lobby seine behauptung
finde ich völlig daneben ich bin nicht
für die vermieter oder für die mieter
die soziale marktwirtschaft gt ad
absurdum geführt weil auch der mieter
über eine kaltmiete erhöhung dann
betroffen ist oder gar er bekommt keine
wohnung mehr weil er vielleicht kinder
hat eine große familie hat und damit zu
viel heizt man verhandele weiter heißt
es aus der regierung heute kleines
problem ist bleibt nicht mehr viel zeit
in dieser legislatur und in der
unionsfraktion will man hart bleiben
dann gab es heute nochmal treffen der
ostdeutschen regierungschefs mit der
bundeskanzlerin und dort deutliche worte
von angela merkel in richtung des
ost-beauftragten der bundesregierung
marco wanderwitz cdu
sie werde sich nie damit abfinden dass
man es als gegeben hinnimmt wenn
menschen sich von der demokratie
abwenden sagte sie wanderwitz hat der
letzte woche davon gesprochen dass ein
teil der ostdeutschen wähler der
demokratie den rücken gekehrt habe und
ein teil der afg wähler dauerhaft für
die demokratie verloren sei ganz aktuell
reingekommen jetzt diese nachricht als
luftfahrtbundesamt erlaubt vorerst keine
flüge russischer fluggesellschaften mehr
nach deutschland
das hat das bundesverkehrsministerium
vor einer stunde mitgeteilt deutschland
reagiert damit offenbar auf die
annullierung von lufthansa flügen nach
russland für den monat juni
diese könnten nicht stattfinden weil die
russische luftfahrtbehörde keine
rechtzeitige genehmigung für flüge der
lufthansa erteilt habe da besonders mal
nachfragen in berlin bei conti manager
controller was steckt da dahinter ein
technisches abstimmungsproblem oder ein
echtes zerwürfnis ja da spitzt man in
diesen zeiten natürlich die ohren und
tatsächlich hat das
bundesverkehrsministerium das zuständig
ist auch direkt drauf geschaut und
gerade eben auch für aufklärung gesorgt
es handelt sich nicht um eine von der
bundesregierung veranlasste
sanktionsmaßnahmen sondern es geht darum
dass es hier eine unregelmäßigkeit gibt
in den genehmigungen im luftverkehr
zunächst hatte russland im jahr 2020
also letztes jahr schon wegen der korona
pandemie den takt verändert indem man
sich gegenseitig diese genehmigungen
erteilt jetzt erfolgt das teilweise
monatlich man muss also immer genau
drauf gucken und jetzt anfang juni fiel
also auch für den juni wurde von
russland keine ein fluggenehmigung für
deutsche
über erteilt darauf hin dass es auch
üblich in der luftfahrt praxis hat auch
das deutsche luftfahrtbundesamt erst mal
gesagt wir setzen unsere genehmigungen
auch aus das ist also eine technische
frage warum es genau dazu gekommen ist
können wir nicht sagen aber wir haben
gerade eben von der lufthansa die
information bekommen dass nun doch alle
genehmigungen vorliegen dass also flüge
für juni abgesichert sind von und nach
russland und das damit dieses problem
erst einmal behoben ist man muss
allerdings dazu sagen dass eine so
kleine information so viel aufregung
auch hier in berlin auslöst zeigt ganz
deutlich wie angespannt das deutsch
russische verhältnis momentan ist auf
jeden fall vielen dank und alaa für
diese aufklärung heute abend jetzt in
der sendung unser nächstes thema die
korona lage zunächst mal die hier bei
uns in deutschland da meldet das
robert-koch-institut vier 1917
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind 2291 mehr als vergangenen mittwoch
außerdem kamen 179 todesfälle dazu die
bundesweite inzidenz liegt jetzt bei
36,8 während in europa die korona lage
generell deutlich besser geworden ist
geht die entwicklung in südamerika in
die andere richtung
besonders betroffen im moment ist peru
mit seinen 33 millionen einwohnern nach
kritik durch die whu wurden die korona
zahlen neu berechnet und das land hat
jetzt mit abstand die höchste corona
sterblichkeitsrate weltweit
offiziell gibt es mehr als 180.000
corona tote minuten line aus berichtet
die friedhöfe von lima wie alles
überwuchern de schlingpflanzen sprengen
sie die grenzen der neun millionen statt
doch für joel bautista der mit 45 jahren
corona starb war nirgendwo mehr platz
viele tage lang suchte seine schwester
vergeblich
wir haben nun entschieden ihn im
vorgarten zu begraben was soll ich
machen mit meinem toten bruder zu hause
pure verzweiflung die ein ganzes land
erfasst und nun wird klar die lage ist
noch schlimmer als gedacht so eine
expertenkommission der regierung die
zahl der cobit 19 toten bis mai 2021
liegt bei 180 1764 das entspricht
beinahe eine verdreifachung hauptgrund
dafür
bisher wurden nur verstorbene mit
positiv-test gezählt nun auch die mit
cupid 19 symptomen angehörige vor lenas
kliniken sind fassungslos
ich weiß nicht ob die regierung uns
belügt oder die wahrheit erzählt jeden
tag werden hier tote herausgebracht
unter den opfern auch zahlreiche ärzte
und pfleger perus korrigierte statistik
bleibt womöglich kein einzelfall
die weltgesundheitsorganisation geht
davon aus dass die wahre zahl der korona
toten in vielen ländern deutlich höher
liegt
israel bekommt ein neues staatsoberhaupt
den früheren oppositionsführer kizza
herzog das parlament wählte den
60-jährigen in geheimer abstimmung mit
großer mehrheit
es ist das erste mal dass der sohn eines
früheren präsidenten in das höchste
staatsamt gewählt wurde
herzog kündigte an präsident aller
israelis sein zu wollen und sich für
einheit in dem politisch gespaltenen
land einzusetzen
die usa erinnern an einen der
schlimmsten fälle rassistischer gewalt
in der geschichte des landes das
massaker von teils seien oklahoma vor
100 jahren brannte ein weißer ob dort
ein ganzes stadtviertel nieder etwa
10.000 menschen wurden obdachlos viele
schwarze ermordet schätzungen gehen von
bis zu 300 toten aus
die täter wurden nie bestraft als erster
us-präsident ist joe biden jetzt zum
gedenken in der stadt tampa live
berichtet sie sind die letzten
überlebenden 100 107 und 106 jahre alt
und ein jahrhundert mussten sie warten
bis ein präsident der usa nach tölzer
kommt um über das zu sprechen was das
land jahrzehntelang totgeschwiegen
nur weil die geschichte schweigt heißt
es nicht dass es nicht stattgefunden hat
dunkelheit können viel verbergen aber
sie löst nichts aus news von alice viola
fletcher und lässt ihr ende lebten 1921
mit ihren familien in greenwood in
diesem wohlhabenden stadtteil ging es
vielen schwarzen besser als anderswo
sie waren kaufleute anwälte ärzte doch
das änderte sich in der nacht zum ersten
juni 1921 ein wütender mob zug durch die
straßen plünderte häuser erschoss die
bewohner und das alles wegen eines
gerüchts ein junger schwarzer hatte
angeblich eine 17-jährige weiße in einem
aufzug angegriffen
eine zeitung macht daraus eine
schlagzeile obwohl es keine beweise gab
die situation zwischen schwarzen und
weißen eskaliert schmerzhafte
erinnerungen bis heute immer noch
schwarze männer die erschossen
ich höre schreie ich habe das massaker
jeden tag durchlebt schätzungen zu den
toten gehen weit auseinander zwischen 36
und 300 verantwortung übernimmt niemand
erst 1996 wird ein denkmal errichtet
entschädigungen gab es nie durch die
rufe danach werden lauter wir sind es
leid opfer einer leeren symbole zu sein
wandgemälde uns gewidmete park banker
auf den wir darüber nachdenken können
was passiert ist nichts davon ist eine
wiedergutmachung
es sind nur erste schritte der usa zur
aufklärung dieser geschichte die heute
so aktuell ist die verein 100 jahren
sieht so gerechtigkeit aus diese frage
treibt gerade viele in italien um nach
dem giovanni brusca jetzt aus dem
gefängnis freikommt das ist der mann der
den mafia jäger giovanni falcone
ermordet hatte und wohl 150 weitere
menschen mindestens brusca den sie in
italien das schwein nennen hatte 25
jahre im gefängnis gesessen seine
freilassung entspricht den gesetzen und
löst gleichzeitig diskussionen aus
andreas postel
am 23 mai 1992 stirbt italiens
legendärer mafiajäger giovanni falcone
durch die explosion von 500 kilogramm
tnt
im november 93 wird auf sizilien der 13
jährige sohn eines mafia komplizen
entführt getötet und in salzsäure
aufgelöst giovanni brusca ist nicht
irgendein krimineller sondern der wohl
brutalste mafioso der je für die
italienische cosa nostra gemordet hat
die nachricht von seiner vorzeitigen
freilassung aus einem gefängnis in rom
sorgt italienweit für empörung und
diskussion
man fühlt sich vom staaten nicht
respektiert in dieser stadt hätte uns
eigentlich gerechtigkeit garantieren
auch in brust gas heimatort sind die
menschen verunsichert viele leute werden
unbewusst angst haben denn es ist
einfach nicht schön mit einem zu tun
haben zu müssen der 150 morde begangen
hat die sache ist komplex brusca wurde
deshalb nach 25 jahren entlassen weil er
in der haft die omerta bracht das
schweigegebot der mafia er wurde zum
kronzeugen der italienischen regierung
und gab viele wichtige hinweise zur
verbrechensbekämpfung in den kommenden
vier jahren gilt für den 64-jährigen die
sogenannte freiheit und der polizeiliche
aufsicht am heutigen tag der republik
ist italien einmal mehr schmerzlich
bewusst dass der kampf gegen die mafia
wohl nicht ohne kronzeugen aus kommt
jetzt in der sendung nachrichten zum
uneingeschränkt freuen und die hat mir
versprochen dass zum beispiel die zurück
in der erfolgsspur sind deutschlands
eishockey spieler bei der
weltmeisterschaft in riga nach zuletzt
drei niederlagen wurde gegen gastgeber
lettland leidenschaftlich gekämpft der
lohn das 2 1 und der viertelfinaleinzug
torwart mathias niederberger gilt der
größte dank denn spielerisch kann die
deutsche mannschaft gegen lettland nur
selten überzeugen sie profitiert
vielmehr von einem perfekten start und
der unbekümmertheit von jason peter k
gerade mal 19 jahre alt der früh zum 1
trifft
ja ich habe die die scheibe relativ
frühe form von außen bekommen und dann
hatte ich schon relativ lang wechsel
deswegen wollte ich das ding einfach
aufs kurze eck zum glück eingegangen
marcel noebels erhöht kurz darauf in der
siebten minute auf 2 0
danach wird vor allem stark verteidigt
lettland gelingt nur noch das 1 2 1 sieg
der moral der anspruch ist mittlerweile
freilich ein anderer
wir haben gezeigt dass wir eishockey
spielen können wir haben wir haben gegen
die großen nationen super gespielt
morgen im viertelfinale können sie es
beweisen gegen die schweiz
zehn jahre nach seinem abschied als
spieler beim fc bayern münchen kehrt
mark van bommel in die
fußball-bundesliga zurück als trainer
des vfl wolfsburg der niederländer ist
die wunschlösung er unterschrieb einen
vertrag bis 2023 alexanders wäre steht
als erster deutscher tennisprofi in der
dritten runde der french open allerdings
war sein weiterkommen paris kein
spaziergang romans ab juli mit dem
typischen selbstvertrauen eines
qualifikanten der vor dem eigentlichen
turnier bereits drei siege feierte der
hier aufschlagende favorit alexander
zverev bekommt das früh zu spüren der
23-jährige russe zwingt den deutschen
mit couragierten spiel in den tie-break
den aber gewinnt wäre dann mit bravour
und überzeugt auch in den nächsten
beiden sätzen mit starken tennis in den
wichtigen momenten auch zur begeisterung
seines vaters obwohl zverev in jedem
satz einmal geprägt wird sagt er ohne
satzverlust mit 7 zu 6 6 zu 3 und 7 zu 6
ein großartiger test für den weiteren
turnierverlauf nächste alles gut prima
freut mich sehr
dann haben wir jetzt noch das hier
passend zum sport und zum wetter für sie
wer mit dem hubschrauber um die
hochhäuser im reichen westen von london
kurvt sieht seit neuestem genau diesen
pool ganz aus glas im zehnten stock
zwischen zwei gebäuden hier kann man so
eine 25 meter bahnen quasi quer durch
die luft ziehen
der pool soll den luxus in dem wohn und
geschäftsgebäude abrunden und vielleicht
ja auch den nicht ganz so sonnen
sicheren londoner sommer haben sie lust
bekommen auf sowas dann wäre ein
lottogewinn hilfreich hier sind die
gewinnzahlen 1 10 entschuldigung 10 14
15 35 39 45 superzahl 0
weitere gewinnzahlen lotto zdf.de im zdf
text auf seite 55 7 im osten sonnig im
westen gewittrig das ist die wetter
kurzfassung die langfassung hat gleich
katja horneffer ich empfehle ihnen wie
immer das heute journal mit der kollegin
marietta slomka um 21.45 und ab morgen
freut sich hier barbara hahlweg auf sie
ich sagte dankeschön fürs zuschauen und
wünsche im namen des gesamten teams ein
angenehmer abend tschüss
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren heute sogar
ein kleines tief von der ostsee über den
am morgen weiter zur nordsee und das
brachte auch einige schauer und gewitter
im nordosten gleichzeitig wurde die luft
von südwesten deutlich schwerer und dann
entwickelten sich bereits am mittag die
ersten gewitterwolken über dem
schwarzwald auch jetzt am abend müssen
wir uns noch auf schauer und gewitter
einstellen lässt sich des rheins aber
auch richtung schwarzwald und
schwäbischer alb und auch in schleswig
holstein sind einige gewitter unterwegs
im laufe der nacht lassen die schauer
und gewitter immer mehr nach da beruhigt
sich die lage
dass aber die schwül-warme gewitter luft
im westen bereits angekommen ist merken
wir an den milden nach temperaturen im
westen sinken sie auf 16 bis 11 grad im
osten ist es dagegen kühler da sinken
die werte auf 12 bis 7 grad die höchsten
temperaturen morgen erwarten wir an der
elbe dort werden 28 grad erreicht sonst
klettern die werte auf 24 bis 27 grad
nur an der see ist es etwas kühler
vormittags strahlt die sonne von der
nordseeküste bis zum alpenrand aber im
westen da brodelt es bereits der gibt's
die ersten regenschauer und gewitter und
die weiten sich dann am nachmittag aus
dann können lokal eng grenzt durchaus
unwetter dabei sein
also gewitter die mit hagel platzregen
und sturmböen verbunden sind und solche
gewitter gibt es dann auch noch am
freitag genauso wie am samstag erst am
sonntag beruhigt sich die lage bei
temperaturen von 18 bis 25 grad schön
aber noch